becoming a pirate battling low
self-esteem losing to a skateboarder
with a handful of grass thanos is one of
the most fearsome villains the marvel
cinematic universe has ever seen but you
won't believe how different he is in the
comics
a great villain needs to start with a
great name darth vader wouldn't be
nearly as scary if his name had been
doug instead on that front thanos
establishes himself quite well with the
moniker that sounds otherworldly and
fearsome when you hear it for the first
time but just like darth vader used to
be called anakin and even annie thanos
did not start out with such an awesome
and terrifying name in the comics the
creature the universe would one day come
to know as the mad titan was born with
the name dion given to him by his mother
that's right the guy who would someday
make the avengers quake in their boots
was born with a name that sounds more
suitable for a barista than a
supervillain fortunately the mother of
dion took one look at his monstrous
little mug after he was born and
realized he needed an appropriately
fearsome name thus dion's mom felt
compelled to change her son's name to
something more befitting of the
supervillain audiences love to hate
you're much more of a thanos
the mcu has given us some pretty
incredible entrances from tony stark
emerging from the cave in iron man to
the iconic portal scene of avengers
endgame but no entry scene is more
badass than thanos a rival in 2018's
avengers infinity war in which he makes
thor his hostage man handles the hulk
and effortlessly subdues loki infinity
war's opening makes it utterly clear
that thanos is not only equal to the
avengers but far above them in terms of
strength intelligence and resources and
yet this cool and collected warlord
doesn't quite match up to the way thanos
was depicted in his earlier appearances
in fact he started out in a much sillier
state that can be best summed up with
the word thanos copter when thanos shows
up in 1978's spidey super stories number
39 he uses a regular looking helicopter
with his name plastered on it during his
search for the cosmic cube later on in
the story thanos is defeated by a young
skateboarder who attacks him with grass
thanos attempts to recruit the tween to
assist him in his evil deeds but he's
rejected and hauled off to jail in
handcuffs by the police not so
inevitable now huh
the biggest trick that the mcu played on
fans of marvel comics was completely
changing the motivation that drives
thanos the mad titan in the movies
thanos is essentially an eco-terrorist
who thinks killing off half of all life
is the only way to save the rest of
civilization from collapsing due to
depleted resources the plan has a deeply
twisted but theoretically magnanimous
logic thanos comes across as someone who
thinks of himself as saving the universe
even if he wants to do so through
horrific means however thanos has a far
more selfish and bizarre motivation in
the comics he wants to impress the
physical embodiment of death with whom
he is in love by destroying life on a
cosmic scale this motivation is actually
referenced by a servant of thanos in the
mid-credits scene of 2012's the avengers
as he advises his master that taking on
humanity may prove difficult
to challenge
them is to court
death
it seems thanos likes the sound of that
thanos's motivation was changed by the
time avengers infinity war came around
as the writers felt that his
relationship with death would prove too
complex for the already sprawling mcu
if you were to ask someone who the
greatest villain the mcu has ever known
is chances are the reply is going to be
thanos the man is so powerful so
single-minded in his goals and so
completely impervious to most of the
attacks by earth's mightiest heroes that
it is difficult to imagine him as
anything other than the ultimate bad guy
the truth is thanos is far too
intelligent to remain firmly rooted in
evil after so many adventures and
experiences in the comics on occasion
the mad titan works on the side of good
and even teams up with heroes in pursuit
of a common goal now and again for
instance at the conclusion of 1991's the
infinity gauntlet the avengers team up
with thanos to stop nebula when she
takes the gems for herself during the
mid-90s crossover event blood and
thunder thor embarks upon a maddened
path of destruction after all the heroes
fail to stop his rampage thanos is
called in to stall thor long enough for
the others to cure the god of thunder's
madness there's even the time thanos
actually saves deadpool's life by
granting him immortality thanos doesn't
do this out of a sense of niceness
though no he's just jealous of the fact
that death has fallen in love with
deadpool and he wants to prevent them
from ever being together
one of the biggest factors that makes
thanos in the mcu a debatably
sympathetic figure is his apparent love
for his daughter gamora even though he
ends up killing her to obtain the soul
stone it's made entirely clear that she
was the most important person in the
world to him his decision continues to
tear him up inside for the rest of his
life what did it cost
everything
in the comics thanos has many more
children than nebula and gamora and
unlike his adopted assassin daughters
from the mcu he sires a lot of them
personally thane the secret son of the
mad titan and an inhuman is probably the
most well known of thanos's numerous
offspring but thane's secret history
pales in comparison to the sordid story
of thanos and the rest of his children
as detailed in the 2013 mini-series
thanos rising the series shows thanos
attempting to turn away from his violent
path by becoming a navigator on a pirate
ship as he does he meets and beds women
from several planets many of whom have
his biological children at first thanos
does not harm any of his intergalactic
descendants but after becoming
infatuated with death yet again he vows
to prove his devotion to her by tracking
down every one of his children and their
mothers and slaughtering them all
the first thing avengers infinity war
establishes about thanos is that he's
pretty much unbeatable the mad titan
defeats not just loki not just thor not
just hulk but all three of them in a
single scene the trend of thanos taking
on multiple avengers at the same time
continues all the way through to the end
of avengers end game if you're familiar
with the mcu movies and haven't gotten
around to reading a ton of comics you
could be forgiven for thinking that
thanos is far and away the most powerful
virtually unbeatable character in the
marvel universe at least outside of what
if but thanos in the comics has actually
been defeated handily many times by much
lesser threats than the combined might
of all the avengers jim the skater boy
subdued thanos with the cosmic cube in
spidey stories number 39. thor took
thanos down on his own in dan jurgens
thor number 25 and kang the conqueror
reduced him to a skeleton in avengers
meck strike number 4. most infamously
though thanos lost a one-on-one battle
against squirrel girl a hero with the
power to talk to squirrels the mad
titan's worst enemy though himself
thanos has been beaten multiple times by
his own subconscious thanks to his
inferiority complex one of the most
shocking mcu moments is when thanos
faces the hulk for the first time in
avengers infinity war at first what
appears to be a fair fight is merely
thanos having fun with the green
behemoth before putting him down in a
most brutal fashion the beating that
thanos delivers to hulk is so resounding
that he's essentially knocked into the
next movie clearly infinity war does not
depict the hulk as the strongest there
is which is a bit of a departure from
how he's traditionally represented in
the comics thanos and hulk have clashed
a number of times with varying outcomes
but the mad titan has admitted that he
is weary of engaging the hulk in direct
combat the comic book version of hulk is
famously able to grow his strength in
proportion to his anger thanos knows
that while he may be able to match
hulk's power at the start of a fight he
is in danger of losing the longer the
fight goes thanos's thoughts on the
matter becomes clear in the thanos quest
number one when the mad titan muses
about an opponent his strength seems to
grow in direct proportion to his anger
in many ways i assume this is what it
would be like battling the terran
behemoth the hulk a conflict i've sought
to avoid over the years
perhaps no other character in the mcu
associated with thanos got shafted
during the transition to live action as
much as drax the destroyer in the first
guardians of the galaxy movie drax
reveals that thanos killed his wife and
daughter as a result he has dedicated
his life to a singular mission drax aka
the destroyer since his wife and family
were killed he's been on a rampage
across the galaxy in his search for
vengeance
after that drax's personal vendetta
against thanos is mostly sidelined and
he never poses any direct threat to
thanos on his own in the comics drax is
very much a big deal for the mad titan
according to his origin story the
destroyer was created by thanos father
to be the one person who could put a
stop to his terrible son's universe wide
rampage again and again drax fights
thanos and ruins his plans even managing
to personally facilitate the death of
thanos at one point it's a shame the mcu
never fully realized just how big a
threat drax posed to thanos something
that the on-screen drax dave bautista
has not been so stoked about the
famously shirtless actor has gone on
record saying he's disappointed by the
mcu's very limited amount of interaction
between the two characters
one of the tensest parts of avengers
infinity war is when iron man spider-man
and doctor strange decide to come and
dear thanos's ship in order to fly to
his home planet and confront the mad
titan on his own turf we don't get to
see just how far the ship has to fly but
it is implied that it has to travel a
great distance to get to thanos's home
planet of titan titan is far enough from
earth that tony stark almost doesn't
survive the trip home at the start of
avengers end game in a ship with limited
fuel but in the comics titan is in the
same solar system as earth thanos isn't
technically born on a planet at all
instead he sired on the moon of saturn
called titan home to a special species
of eternals known as titanians when
thanos is born among the titanians his
deformed appearance makes him an outcast
thanos's woes are further compounded by
the presence of his instantly popular
brother eros also known as star fox thus
thanos chooses to leave titan and become
an intergalactic warlord at an early age
to understand thanos's primary
motivation in the mcu we must understand
his home planet of titan as thanos
explains to doctor strange titan was a
paradise that ultimately succumbed to
overpopulation thanos tried his best to
save his planet and his people but their
society was nevertheless destroyed
they called me a madman
and what i predicted came to balance
[Music]
thus thanos vows to stop overpopulation
from destroying the other civilizations
of the universe this backstory makes it
clear or at least implies that thanos
once had a great love for titan and its
people nothing could be further from the
truth when it comes to thanos in the
comics though there the citizens of
titan considered the future mad titan a
deformed mutant to the extent that his
own mother was convinced she had given
birth to evil incarnate and tried to
kill him the rest of thanos's peers were
just as hostile to him prompting his
early departure from titan consumed by
dreams of death and destruction thanos
spends many years honing his mind and
body into the most dangerous weapon in
the universe after he grows an
experience and gathers vast resources in
his travels across the cosmos thanos
returns to titan to personally lay waste
to his people including his mother
perhaps thanos's most well-defined
quality in the mcu the thing that makes
him the most compelling villain and the
most formidable foe is his complete
unwavering belief in his own logic and
goals once thanos decides that half of
all life needs to be destroyed there's
nothing anyone can say to change his
mind this overwhelming stubbornness
carries thanos through to killing his
beloved daughter gamora and battling the
combined might of the avengers but in
the comics thanos is not always so
completely sure of himself even in the
infinity gauntlet saga arguably the
definitive thanos story the mad titan's
doubts run so deep that he
subconsciously wills himself to lose in
the mini-series thanos rising the mad
titan grows so remorseful of his actions
and the destruction that he's caused
that he turns away from his conquering
goals and becomes a navigator on a
pirate ship instead finally in the comic
the thanos quest number two after thanos
becomes the owner of the infinity stones
and seeks to finally get together with
his beloved death she informs him that
he is now too powerful to be her mate
this moves thanos to tears of regret and
he muses that all his efforts have ended
in a hollow victory
[Music]